المعركه الكبرى في اوكرانيا ستبدا خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله والسؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه هنا من سيضرب اولا وعيت سؤال طرحته
صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه لنبدا بخط
المواجهه في الجنوب الاوكراني الذي يبلغ
طوله 1200 كيلو متر ومن المتوقع وفق خبراء
عسكريين تحدثوا للجاردن ان تندلع هناك اشد
مراحل الحرب دراوى منذ بدايه الحرب وفي
انتظار اطلاق شراره الحرب وشراره المعركه
القادمه روسيا تعمل على تقويه قواتها عبر
تحريك وتوجيه اقتصاد البلاد نحو الصناعه
الحربيه من اجل انتاج طبعا دبابات وصواريخ
جديده وفقا لهؤلاء الخبراء بعدما مثلت
المرحله الاولى من العمليه العسكريه حرب
استنزاف كبيره للجانب الروسي همم طبعا
للكرملين كلفته الاف الجنود بالاضافه الى
الخسائر التي لحقت بالترسانه الصاروخيه
التي استخدمت فيها وستخدمت بقصف البنيه
التحتيه طاقه باوكرانيا اما الجانب
الاوكراني فيتحضر لاخذ زمام المبادره
والشروع بالهجوم اولا والسباق الهجمات
الروسيه ولكن غياب الاسلحه الثقيله
لاختراق المواقع الروسيه يتسبب لها بحاله
احباط الا اذا كان للدبابات الغربيه التي
استلمتها مؤخرا كلام اخر هناك ثلاث جبهات
يمكن ان تكون ساحه للمعارك الضاريه في
الربيع المقبل ويمكن ان يكون حسم اي واحده
منها منعرجا حاسما لهذه الحرب جبهه الشرق
وهنا نتحدث عن لهانسك ودنياسك التي كانت
مسرحا لاشد المعارك في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه وهي طبعا اكثر الاماكن احتماليه
لشنها جمال كبرى من كلا الجانبين في
الربيع المقبل جبهه الجنوب في اتجاه جزيره
القرم طبعا وهي الجبهه الاهم بالنسبه
للطرفين الاكراني والروسيه لانها طبعا
ستقرر نتيجه الحرب برمتها سواء ش القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه لهجوم الاول في الشرق
ام لا وتبقى طبعا جبهه الشمال حيث تحشد
روسيا قواتها للتدريب بيلاروسيا ولكن يبقى
هذا الامر خدعه من قبل موسكو لابعاد
القوات الاوكرانيه عن الجنوب والشرق بحسب
الصحيفه